our other main story this morning
another Minister has quit the
government's overt resumes brexit
withdrawal agreement Sam Jamar the
universities and Science Minister
becomes the seventh minister now to
resign over the deal he's described it
as naive and one that will leave Britain
worse off for mr. jean-marc joins me now
from our westminster studio very good
morning to you good morning so we are
just 11 days away from the meaningful
vote in parliament why have you decided
to go now well I've been thinking about
the pyre the Prime Minister's proposals
over the last two weeks and I sort of
reluctantly came to the conclusion that
we actually don't have a deal at all
what we've got is a deal in name only
we've got a wish list of aspirations
which we intend to negotiate with the EU
after we've left when we've lost our
voice our veto and our vote we will have
no leverage the EU will set all the
timelines and we will be going against
27 countries my experience of the
Galileo negotiations tells me that we
are going to get horribly crippled by
the EU if we go down this path and once
that hit me it's not easy to resign it's
not easy to resign when you are doing a
job you love in government I just felt
you know it was best to let the Prime
Minister know that I could not support
her sooner rather than later
yeah Galileo is the EU satellite project
just explained to our viewers who
perhaps aren't aware of the details of
Galileo what it is specifically that
you're so angry about well so Galileo is
a sat-nav system for the EU that the UK
contributed over a billion to you now
before the ink was dry on the transition
deal the EU decided to boot as out now
if Galileo is important to the UK
because our military depends on the
security and encryption parts of it and
a lot of that was built by UK companies
now the EU shakes stack the deck in such
a way that the UK just could not carry
on having the Prime Minister's right to
say that we are terminated
those discussions and we'll build our
own now but that is a foretaste of how
the EU will behave in these negotiations
it is like going to play a football
match where the other side is here the
team playing against you they are the
referee and they make the rules as well
and so if the EU is if you're playing
against the EU and you're not on their
side it is very hard to come out in a
position where your national interest
will be enhanced I don't think anyone
would say that this is the very best
deal the Prime Minister herself accepts
that it's not the very best deal but it
is the only deal and in any divorce
there has to be compromised we've seen
Michael Gove in the press today saying
that it is the best deal that's on offer
the culture secretary jeremy wright also
saying the same thing it ends free
movement it controls farming we get
control back of Fisheries we have the
opportunity to create our own trade
deals surely this is the best that we
can do for now why can't you accept that
the mistake you're making is assuming
that there is actually a deal these are
the things we would like to achieve I
think freedom of movement credits the
Prime Minister she's done quite a lot
but everything else these are things we
would like to achieve in a negotiating
process in which the clock will be
against us we haven't as a country after
two years of the brexit vote even
decided on the big issues where do we
stand on independent trade policy versus
frictionless trade with the EU how do we
resolve the Northern Ireland issue in
the long term what we want to do on
fisheries what we want to do in
agriculture all the big questions are
still in play so we are not at the end
of the process we are actually at the
beginning of a process in which the
negotiation is to come what is being
presented as a deal is where we hope to
land in the best possible scenario I
don't believe that is credible I'm
setting ourselves up for failure ok so
you're saying that a second referendum a
people's vote can't be ruled out so why
don't you come off the fence and say
what you want is a people's vote a bit
absolutely Frank about that is an
offence sitting I I mean III think
I'm saying is that if Parliament is
deadlocked we shouldn't rule out of hand
letting the people decide and I think
that works that is in the interest of
both levers and remainders and that
doesn't in any way D legitimize the
first referendum we all know more about
the EU today than we knew then and we in
a new referendum we also know more about
the terms of departure so I think that a
if Parliament is deadlocked this could
be a way out of it the Prime Minister
has already taken one step towards this
position she's appealing to the country
to put pressure on MPs to our vote for
her deal why didn't he let the country
decide the Prime Minister has also said
that a people's vote isn't going to
happen but let me ask you this if as is
widely expected the vote doesn't go her
way in a week or so time do you think
the Prime Minister could be the person
to say okay well now is the time to take
it back to the people absolutely I think
I think the Prime Minister could do that
and she could put her deal alongside it
a number of other options to the country
I think that could break the logjam but
from how I looked at it this is the
biggest vote possibly in my political
career and I just thought I've got to
come I've got a vote in the way that I
think is right and the way that is in
the national interest and it's for
everyone to do the same and then when we
get to the other side there are other
options that note that we need to think
about rather than focus the false choice
that is being posed which is the Prime
Minister's deal or chaos okay so what
would you like to see I mean you've
touched on it partially if a Norway
model with a customs union was an option
would you be happy with that despite the
fact that of course freedom of movement
is part and parcel well the problem with
the Norway model is you sign up to
everything and you but you have you have
no voice you have no say you have no
veto so the only thing you've achieved
by
leaving the EU on the Norway model is
that you've left your veto in the room
and I think that kind of democratic
deficit and loss of sovereignty is one
that the British public would never
really accept I happen to think that I'm
as a country given that we need for our
own ambitions to have a preeminent place
in Europe we're either all in or all out
you would David Cameron's parliamentary
private secretary for a time do you
think he made a huge error calling for
this referendum in the first place well
the referendums are unpredictable you
never know what questions people are
really going to be answering and so even
when I say there should be a second
referendum I am mindful of that but I
think he felt and I spoke to him a lot
about it that there was going to be a
time when the question about our EU
membership had to be settled once and
for all clearly that is not the case but
I think what is missing from the debate
and was missing in the referendum
campaign and is still missing from the
debate is reckoning with the public
about the real trade-offs that have to
be made and I'm not saying just say it's
a compromise let's go for this but every
option involves trade-offs and we've got
to explain it to the public and level
with people about what it is and I think
in that way we'll have a more mature
debate and I think those who say that
somehow doing that would turn the public
of politics are probably under
estimating the maturity of our political
democracy